no
[Música]
actualizamos la economía con jorge
hurtado jorge bienvenido nuevamente
vamos a iniciar hablando entonces de
alemania donde renunció el presidente
del bundesbank así que se trata de james
whitman quien entregó hoy su renuncia
que tendrá efecto hasta el 31 de
diciembre y argumentó motivos personales
whitman ocupaba el cargo de presidente
del bundesbank el banco central alemán y
era considerado ficha clave en el
consejo de gobierno del banco central
europeo dijo en una carta que tras diez
años consideraba un buen momento para
pasar a una siguiente página en su vida
el banquero agradeció a sus colegas del
banco central europeo señalando que hubo
una atmósfera abierta y constructiva en
los días en las discusiones más
difíciles durante los últimos años el
gobierno alemán lo había designado en
febrero del 2019 para un nuevo período
de ocho años a cargo del banco central
whitman llegó allí en 2011 con sólo 42
años y se convirtió rápidamente en el
presidente más joven del banco central
alemán la economía alemana va a crecer
2,4 por ciento este año por debajo de lo
esperado debido a los problemas de las
cadenas de suministros mundiales de
materias primas y componentes según los
principales institutos económicos de ese
país hoy en argentina el gobierno
congeló los precios de cientos de
productos se trata de 1.400 productos
vinculados a la alimentación que fueron
congelados hasta principio de 2022 luego
de las conversaciones con la cámara de
la industria alimentaria que fracasaron
en ese país antes de la decisión estatal
la principal cámara de la industria
alimentaria copal rechazó la propuesta
del gobierno y criticó a los
funcionarios por tratar de forzar un
acuerdo unilateral según este organismo
que representa regula unas 35 cámaras y
más de 14.500 empresas de alimentos y
bebidas el llamado del gobierno a
congelar los precios no le había dado
suficientes garantías al sector el
gobierno de alberto fernández batalla
para controlar la inflación que aumentó
un 3,5 por ciento de septiembre llegó a
una tasa anual de más de el 50 por
ciento algo que además de frenar el
crecimiento económico complica el nivel
de vida de los argentinos que a
propósito esto tienen que decir
para evitar políticos realmente si me
preguntan para mí no lo
que digan que congelan precios cuidados
precio congelado mentiras no crean nada
sigo llegando sigo sin llegar a fin de
mes así que no sigo sin creer en eso
porque usa billeteras digitales todavía
no bueno vamos a ver cómo nos va con la
de facebook porque está probando su
billetera digital llamada novi y lo hace
de raúl en guatemala según la empresa la
billetera novi es una herramienta que va
a ayudar a los usuarios a enviar y
recibir dinero del extranjero de forma
instantánea segura y sin cargos según
dave marcus director de facebook
financial el piloto está destinado a
probar las funciones principales y las
capacidades operativas en la atención al
cliente y el cumplimiento la visión a
largo plazo es que este novedoso sistema
pueda ayudar a personas que todavía
carecen de los servicios financieros
básicos novi va a incluir a futuro raúl
transacciones con una cripto moneda
aunque va a depender eso de cómo resulta
este piloto el salvador recientemente
probó el uso del bit coin con el fin de
que miles de ciudadanos reciben remesas
sin intermediarios ni comisiones según
el presidente bucl pero volviendo a
guatemala entre enero y septiembre de
2021 los guatemaltecos que viven en el
exterior principalmente en estados
unidos enviaron a sus familiares unos
11.000 millones de dólares sólo en
remesas sólo en remesa jorge vamos a
hablar ahora perdón de los indicadores
así es bueno vamos con wall street que
abrió en positivo motivado por el precio
del petróleo en asia los inversores
interpretaron como una buena señal que
el fundador de alibaba el
multimillonario jack ma habría viajado
por primera vez al extranjero más de un
año después tras desaparecer
prácticamente de la esfera luego de que
en un discurso criticar a beijing y en
europa el crecimiento es tímido por la
preocupación de los inversores sobre el
impacto de los costos derivados de los
problemas de la cadena de suministros
para finalizar que nos tiene como cifra
del día por la cifra del día tiene que
ver con el bitcoin porque esos bitcoin
en 63 mil 865 dólares es el precio del
bit con hoy la cripto moneda se
encuentra por romper su máximo histórico
esto tras el repunte impulsado por el
lanzamiento del primer fondo cotizado en
bolsa de futuro de bitcoin de eeuu
bitcoin ergo a nadie porque no tengo ni
0,005 jorge muchísimas gracias por toda
la información de economía nos vemos
mañana con más o menos directo hasta
parís naves
[Música]